pasamos a la economía aquí en directo
América ya está con nosotros en el
estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas
noches comenzamos con la noticia que
movió a los mercados en la jornada de
hoy las actas de la última reunión de la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos el
mundo tiembla ante las decisiones que
tomen allí sin duda alguna y es uno de
lo de las estadísticas más seguidas por
supuesto y de los anuncios el que más
siguen los inversores la Fed prevé que
este 2023 los tipos de interés continúen
subiendo e inclusive a un ritmo mucho
mayor si es necesario en un lenguaje
bastante dividido entre quienes están
preocupados por la desaceleración de la
economía y los convencidos de que la
inflación será persistente las actas
dicen que los responsables políticos
acordaron que los tipos tendrían Sí o sí
que continuar subiendo la reserva
Federal realizó varias subidas de tipos
de interés de 75 y 50 puntos básicos en
2022 en busca de frenar la inflación que
había alcanzado ya máximos de 40 años en
ese país el tipo de interés oficial del
Banco Central estadounidense se sitúa
actualmente entre el 450 y el 4,75 por
ciento los funcionarios creen que el
tipo de interés medio para finales este
año podría llegar al 5,6% frente al 5,1
que habían previsto en diciembre pasado
la evaluación la evaluación de la Fed
indica que la economía estadounidense
sigue siendo sólida y que los riesgos
para las perspectivas de inflación
continúan inclinándose al alza la Fed no
descarta la probabilidad de que la
economía estadounidense entre en
recesión en 2023 Y esperan que las
condiciones del mercado laboral se
suavicen a lo largo de este año en ese
orden de ideas Jorge Entonces los
indicadores Cómo se comportaron las
bolsas a raíz de estas decisiones bueno
la renta variable mundial y los
rendimientos de los bonos del tercero de
Estados Unidos bajaron este miércoles ya
que los sólidos datos económicos
recientes aún preocupan a los inversores
por las agresivas subidas de los tipos
de interés esos temores llegaron a
Europa donde las bolsas cerraron a la
baja y en América Latina el efecto
también llegó las acciones de los
mercados emergentes tocaron un mínimo de
casi siete semanas Jorge y una de las
regiones del mundo que se ha beneficiado
de manera indirecta del conflicto en
Europa del este en Ucrania es América
Latina cómo nos ha beneficiado bueno
específicamente gracias al alza de las
materias primas con un incremento en las
exportaciones agropecuarias de gas y
petróleo el aumento de los precios de
los alimentos en los mercados mundiales
también hizo que las exportaciones
agropecuarias brasileñas crecieran por
ejemplo un 36,1% el año pasado hasta los
75 mil millones de dólares en Argentina
los principales complejos agropecuarios
también incrementaron los ingresos un
8,5% hasta los
46,461 millones de dólares por la subida
de los precios en los mercados
internacionales que supuso esta guerra
además de las oportunidades en el sector
agropecuario algunos países aprovecharon
la coyuntura para incrementar sus
exportaciones de gas carbón y petróleo
Santiago un ejemplo es Perú cuyas de gas
natural licuado y petróleo se elevaron
un 57,9% en 2022 también Brasil y
Colombia aumentaron las exportaciones de
petróleo cuyo precio se disparó en 2022
fruto por supuesto de este conflicto en
Europa del este escuchemos que dicen los
economistas al respecto
hay que recordar que la recaudación
tributaria generada por todo el sector
minero y petrolero principalmente es un
dato muy importante en esta recaudación
brasileña y alcanzó niveles elevados de
casi el 2,6% del pib
algo muy por encima de nuestra serie
histórica que también ayudó que la
economía brasileña crezca más y que el
gobierno pueda gastar más también fue un
momento muy difícil para todos los
países pero en términos relativos Brasil
se vio beneficiado
fue beneficiado seguimos hablando de
temas de la región hablamos del fenómeno
de la migración que es un tema
transversal para muchos países pero que
está afectando puntualmente la industria
de café por qué bueno los cafetaleros en
Centroamérica trabajan ya con la mitad
de los recolectores de café que
necesitan por la migración de miles de
personas hacia Estados Unidos esta
escasez de mano de obra para la cosecha
está provocando una caída en los
ingresos del sector por ejemplo en
Honduras las autoridades estiman que al
menos 1000 personas migran diariamente
hacia Estados Unidos para escapar de la
pobreza y la violencia Honduras es El
séptimo productor mundial de café según
Fuentes del sector y hay 250.000
hectáreas de café repartidas entre más
de 100.000 productores allí su cultivo
genera un millón de vídeos y cerca del
38% de todo el producto interno bruto
agrícola según el Instituto hondureño de
café otro país Costa Rica ahí hay casi
94 mil hectáreas de plantaciones de café
que emplean a unos 25 mil recolectores
mayoritariamente nicaragüenses aunque
también hay panameños y costarricenses
por la falta de mano de obra allí ya
prevén una pérdida del 5% de su cosecha
el gobierno pues a veces no nos permite
a todos los nicaragüenses
trabajar libremente porque hay alguna
presión cita bastante presión Pues en el
país y eso nos hace emigrar venir aquí a
este país a trabajar en esta cosecha si
nos ha costado mucho el tema de
recolección porque
la falta de mano de obra sobre todo
nicaragüense que es la que otros años
nos ha venido a ayudar
este año ha sido se disminuyó demasiado
Jorge para el cierre hablemos de la
cifra del día la cifra del día es
bastante controversial hoy 13 mil
dólares entregará a Perú a las familias
de los fallecidos en las protestas en
Perú las manifestaciones comenzaron en
diciembre tras el fallido autogolpe del
expresidente Pedro castillo y exige la
renuncia ahora de la presidenta Dina
boluarte el cierre del Congreso y el
adelanto de las elecciones a este año
Así como la convocatoria de una asamblea
Constituyente el gobierno de boluarte
dijo que dará este este medio de las
familias de los que fallecieron y
también habrá otro monto para quienes
resultaron gravemente heridos tras estas
manifestaciones antigubernamentales
Jorge Pues cifra controvertida como
usted lo decía Muchas gracias por esta
actualización a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]